welcome back to CBS mornings where we
are learning more details from Prince
Harry's upcoming Memoir apparently
accidentally published in the country of
Spain the book called spare offers well
really lays bear life in the royal
family all from Harry's perspective of
course it was scheduled the book rather
to be released next week accompanied by
TV interviews but somebody apparently
made a mistake it's been translated
Charlie dagada is at Buckingham Palace
for us with more Charlie good morning
good morning well we weren't supposed to
be discussing this until next week but
in a major mistake the book was
prematurely put on sale in Spain
yesterday before it was promptly pulled
off the shelves an inside scoop from a
very unhappy former Insider among the
many dropped bombs in Prince Harry's
tell-all Memoir he reveals that he and
Prince William begged his father King
Charles not to marry Camilla now Queen
consort and how he spoke with his
deceased mother Diana through a medium
his reportedly ghost written book spare
largely focuses on just that being the
spare heir to Prince William's
Birthright to the throne detailing
extraordinarily personal at times
painful accounts of growing up in the
royal family and what eventually drove
him and Megan to leave it all behind as
discussed in this Sunday's 60 Minutes
interview with Anderson Cooper what
Megan had to go through was was similar
in some part to what okay and what
committee went through very different
circumstances but then you add in the
race element which was what the Press
British press jumped on straight away I
went into this incredibly naive I had no
idea the British press was so bigoted
hell I was probably bigoted you or the
relationship with with Megan you'd think
you were bigoted before the relationship
with me I don't know
put it this way I didn't see
what I now see what we do see among the
detail personal Revelations losing his
virginity in a field behind a pub to an
older woman is recreational drug use of
cannabis and cocaine one of the more
controversial statements in a book
packed with them is the claim that he
killed 25 Taliban members while serving
in Afghanistan in 2012 breaking an
unspoken code among service members
never to discuss kills much less in
public and further details of the
allegations that his brother William
physically attacked him in an argument
over Megan Diana always used to say to
me that Harry was the backup to William
in the nicest possible way she wanted
Harry to be Williams wingman not as
we've seen his Hitman it's a real
conundrum for the royal family going
forwards so here's the part where we say
no comment from the palace the book
officially comes out in the U.S next
week he got that 60 Minutes interview
this weekend and in an interview here
Prince Harry refuses to comment on
whether he'll be attending his father's
coronation in the spring Nate
Charlie dagger in London thank you